in this video we'll be talking about
cerebral Aqueduct stenosis this is one
type of disorder that blocks the
cerebral Aqueduct the passage way
between the third and the fourth
ventricle this disrupts the normal CSF
flow and ultimately leads to obstructive
hydrophilus so let us try to understand
what is cerebral Aqueduct so this are
the lateral ventricle third and the
fourth ventricle in the human brain the
connection between third and the fourth
ventricle is the cerebral aqueduct in
cerebral aqueductal stenosis this
particular passage way is blocked and
that leads to fluid accumulation in the
ventricles especially in the lateral
ventricles which kind of increases the
intracranial pressure and it dilates The
ventricle wall to an extent that it
leads to a bulging and this is a key
cause of obstructive hydrus
now let's try to understand the cause of
cerebral Aqueduct stenosis there could
be congenital cause or acquired causes
for example there could be de
developmental abnormalities in the
cerebral Aqueduct itself which lead to
an obstruction of the CSF flow there
could be also genetic factors which
might lead to cerebral Aqueduct stenosis
but in terms of acquired factors there
could be tumors infections or
inflammations that might obstruct this
passage way and also there could be
hemorrage or bleeding that lead to a
blockage of these cerebral Aqueduct
which eventually lead to cerebral
aqueductal stenosis anyway cerebral
aqueductal stenosis can be diagnosed
using magnetic resonance imaging so in
an typical MRI image one can clearly see
the cerebral Aqueduct is obstructed and
that has massively dilated the lateral
ventricles which is very distinct in an
MRI image so depending on the severity
this particular condition can be treated
with surgical interventions like
endoscopic third ventricle oomy or
placing a shunt which would drain excess
amount of fluid from the ventricles into
the peronal cavity and thereby improvise
the situation so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe see you in next
video